cualquier afección o enfermedad que dañe
la capacidad del corazón de bombear
sangre puede producir insuficiencia
cardíaca por ejemplo la causa más común
es la cardiopatía coronaria en esta una
sustancia grasosa denominada placa
bloquea los vasos sanguíneos que
alimentan el músculo cardíaco
denominados arterias coronarias
otras causas frecuentes de insuficiencia
cardíaca incluyen la hipertensión
arterial no controlada y la glucemia
elevada en la diabetes
entre las causas menos frecuentes de
insuficiencia cardíaca se incluyen
válvulas cardíacas enfermas infectadas o
dañadas latidos del corazón irregulares
denominados arritmias defectos cardíacos
envenenamiento o abuso de sustancias
enfermedades pulmonares y problemas de
respiración durante el sueño denominados
apnea del sueño